heute geht es darum genauer gesagt darum
wie man richtig dicke knoblauchknollen
anbaut jetzt ist nämlich die perfekte
zeit um knoblauch zu pflanzen und in
diesem video zeige ich dir von der
sortenwahl bis zum pflanzen dann selbst
und auch noch den wichtigsten anbau-
tipps genau wie das ganze funktioniert
[Musik]
wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft und
seit unserem allerersten garten ja mit
knoblauch komplett selbst zu versorgen
das ist also gar nicht so kompliziert
und viele glauben auch immer gar nicht
mag knoblauch so ohne weiteres in
deutschland anbauen kann wir werden ihn
jetzt pflanzen das heißt er überwintert
sogar im beet der ist komplett forst hat
der kann also einiges mehr ab als man so
denkt wenn man knoblauch anbauen möchte
es ist aber wichtig also wenn jetzt
knoblauchknollen suchst du in deinem
garten pflanzen kannst dann ist es
wichtig dass du knoblauch bei bauern
kaufst die in deutschland anbauen es
gibt nämlich ganz viele sorten die er
auf wärmeres an wärmeres klima angepasst
sind weil der meiste knoblauch eben
nicht in deutschland angebaut wird die
man im laden kaufen kann aber im
bioladen oder auf dem wochenmarkt findet
man normalerweise eine auswahl von knoop
leuchten die in deutschland angebaut
wurden und da suchst du dir einfach die
schönsten knollen aus und die kannst du
dann bei dir im garten anbauen aber
bitte nicht knoblauch bei dir zu hause
stecken der in spanien angebaut wurde es
kann sein dass das da nicht so gut
funktionieren würde
es gibt zwei zeit punkte zu denen man
knoblauch pflanzen kann dass es einmal
im herbst im september oder oktober so
dass der knoblauch daneben wie ich eben
gesagt habe im weg überwintert vor dem
winter noch einen wachstumsvorsprung hat
und dann im frühling gleich richtig los
wachsen kann oder im märz da kannst du
auch noch knoblauch pflanzen wenn du es
im herbst vergessen hast dann kriegst du
auch noch eine ernte man ernte denen
dann ende juni anfang juli ungefähr wenn
das laub zu zwei dritteln ungefähr gelb
geworden ist dass es oft um die
sommersonnenwende herum
so lange hat er dann zeit im weg zu
stehen und zu wachsen aber wenn du dem
diesem wachstumsvorsprung gibst und den
im oktober pflanzt oder im september
pflanzt dann hättest du wirklich viel
dickere knollen sind oft ausprobiert
wenn wir im märz gedacht dass so ein
bisschen mehr knop auch heute schon
seien dann haben wir immer gemerkt dass
die im frühling gepflanzten knollen viel
viel weniger ertrag abwerfen also wenn
du die wahl hast dann pflanzen lieber im
herbst aber falls du dieses video im
frühling schaust dann ist jetzt auch
noch ein guter zeitpunkt um das
nachzuholen ist es ja besser eine kleine
ernte zu haben als überhaupt keine und
das funktioniert dann auf jeden fall
auch noch die muskel bach auch nicht
unbedingt aus den zehn anbau und du
kannst auch knöllchen nehmen das ist vor
allem dann sinnvoll wenn du schon mal
knoblauch angriff
hass und der bei dir geblüht hat dann
siehst du dass der an der blüte sich so
ganz kleine knubbelige wie michael
knoblauchzehen gebildet haben das sind
die flächen und aus denen kann man auch
knoblauch anbauen allerdings dauert es
dann bist du so eine knolle ernte zwei
jahre wenn du die zehen aus den normalen
knollen nimmst dann hast du eben im
darauffolgenden sommer schon deine erste
ernte und bei den kirchen müsstest du
ein jahr länger warten
du kannst sie auch schon im
darauffolgenden sommer ernten allerdings
ernst du dann rundlinge das sind
ungefähr so große durchgehend die sind
gar nicht in einzelne 10 unterteilte
knoblauch artige kugeln die natürlich
viel kleiner sind aber die sind auch
super und dann muss es mal nicht so viel
knoblauch schälen sondern kann gleich
den ganzen rundling verwenden das ist
auch schon eine möglichkeit die der mann
hat aber ich finde es viel einfacher und
schneller einfach die ganz normalen
knoblauchzehen zu nehmen wir gerne an ja
super gerne mit kompost wenn du keinen
kompass auf den beeten aus gebracht hast
dann freut sich der knoblauch wenn du da
noch etwas kompost auf den beeten
verteilt und die erde auch gut auf lok
heißt wir werden dann ja ganz ohne
umgraben das heißt wir locker an unseren
beruf sehr gerne mit einer grabegabel da
kann man dann ohne die bodenschichten zu
zerstören oder den boden liegen also
viel stress zubereiten einfach in die
erde stecken und das ganze ein bisschen
lockern
dann können sich die wurzeln besser
ausbreiten und ich finde auch dass man
dann wenn es soweit ist die
knoblauchknollen auch leichter wieder
aus der erde kriegt wenn man die erde
vor dem pflanzen einmal richtig gut
aufgelockert hat dann suchst du dir
deine dicksten knoblauchknollen
herausbricht die auseinander und steckt
die 10 1 10 in die erde und dabei ist es
ganz wichtig dass der spitze teil nach
oben schaut wer aus dem flachen teil die
wurzeln später raus müssen die dann in
den boden nach unten wachsen soll nun
aus dem spitzen teil der teil raus kommt
ja nach oben wachsen soll also da
wirklich darauf achten dass das ganze
richtig in die erde kommt gerade wenn du
hart next sorten anbaut wie diese hier
so einem harten spiel
dazu sage ich gleich auch noch mehr bei
den anderen werde es nicht ganz so
wichtig aber bei den harten exporte
neben schuhen und ihr wisst ja dass ich
sehr auf mischkultur setzte in meinem
garten das heißt dass ich immer
nebeneinander anbau die sich in
irgendeiner form gut tun und den
knoblauch kannst du wunderbar zwischen
erdbeeren stecken
der soll pilzkrankheiten an den
erdbeeren verhindern
dann kannst du ihn neben möhren anbau
und schützt auch die möhre vor der
möhren fliege er hat eine ähnliche
wirkung wie die zwiebel geschrieben und
man will sich ja auch total gerne und
dann soll es auch sehr sehr gut sein
knoblauch in die nähe von obstbäumen zu
pflanzen allerdings musst du darauf
achten dass ihr nicht komplett im
schatten wächst ein bisschen sonne
braucht er auf jeden fall ein guter
pflanzabstand sind ungefähr 15 x 25 cm
ich brauche mein gemüse auch sehr gerne
in rain an das heißt ja ich achte darauf
dass alle knoblauch schön in reih und
glied stehen weil man dann später sehr
leicht machen kann und wenn mal unkraut
wächst dann kann man das auch leichter
entfernen mit einer hacke ohne sich
irgendwie kurz blicken zu müssen
aber ja solange du den abstand einhält
kannst du die natürlich auch kreuz und
quer überall hin pflanzen ich finde dass
wir auch wenn es vielleicht spießig ist
einfacher das gemüse in rain anzubauen
und falls es wenn du den knoblauch
gepflanzt ganz trocken ist bei dir dann
kannst du ihn nach dem pflanzen auch an
gießen das ist aber nicht unbedingt
nötig wir machen das eigentlich nie aber
wenn jetzt wochenlang kein regen
angekündigt wäre dann wäre es ganz
sinnvoll den einmal an zu wissen damit
er in fahrt kommt damit die pflanzen
schneller aufgehen können und dann eben
auch diesen wachstumsvorsprung bekommen
den sie brauchen bevor sie in den winter
gehen wenn ihr pflanzt knoblauch kaufen
möchte dann habt ihr ja auf die wahl
zwischen verschiedenen sorten
ich kann euch da die sorte wkn sehr
empfehlen das ist eine sorte die relativ
kleine knollen bildet und auch in
relativ mickriges laut man denkt dann
immer irgendwas stimmt mit dem nicht
weil der irgendwie längst nicht so
kräftig wächst wie die anderen aber der
schmeckt viel viel besser als alle
sorten die wir sonst ausprobiert haben
so in die dickere knollen bilden wie die
hier sind muratow und der rigi hat diese
sorte letztens auch empfohlen und der
konnte das so perfekt aussprechen ich
habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wie man
es ausspricht weil er ja du ich bleibe
es euch auch nie in zwei unten nochmal
ein
das sind auch sorten mit denen wir super
erfahrungen gemacht haben die auch noch
ertragreicher sind und lecker sind die
auch aber eben nicht ganz so lecker wie
der weg an
die man allerdings eher schwierig
bekommt ich habe den nur bei einem
biobauern bekommen der bei uns in der
nähe wohnt und den anbauen ich habe den
aber noch nirgendwo als pflanzt
knoblauch gesehen falls jemand von euch
den weiß wie man den bekommt schreibt es
gerne in die kommentare und dann gibt es
noch zwei große gruppen unter den
knoblauch sorten zu denen ich euch
eigentlich auch noch was erzählen könnte
das sind die schon eben erwähnt die hart
next so hatten das sind die die so einen
harten stil haben und dies oft next
worden
soft max sind meistens die die man im
supermarkt bekommt weil die maschine
anbau ba sind da ist es wie gesagt nicht
so wichtig dass man die zähne richtig
herum in die erde steckt und deswegen
kann man die auch mit der maschine
pflanzen deswegen ist das meistens der
knoblauch den man im supermarkt bekommt
allerdings sind dies oft next worten oft
nicht so aromatisch wie die hasen
exporten und deswegen brauche ich viel
lieber hartnigk sorten an
das ist was man dann abwägen kann was
man lieber mag ein weiterer vorteil der
software sorten ist dass man die viel
einfacher zu wunderschönen zöpfe
flechten kann wenn man sie dann geerntet
hat das funktioniert mit den
hartnäckigen auch aber die zöpfe werden
nie so richtig schick zumindest nicht
wenn ich das aber das ist es mir wert
wir schneiden die dann einfach so ab
also wir werden die knoten einfach hier
ein kürzen und dann lagern wir die
knollen lohse das funktioniert auch
wunderbar ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
hübsch aber das ist mir jetzt lieber
wenn sie dafür besser schmecken dann
noch ein paar tipps was knoblauch gar
nicht gerne hat ist unkraut also
versucht seine beete möglichste
unkrautfrei zu halten wir haben ja eh
nicht viele probleme mit unkraut in
unserem garten da kommt demnächst
übrigens auch noch ein video zu hier auf
dem kanal also abonniere gerne den kanal
und drückt auch die glocke damit du das
nicht verpasst wir haben quasi überhaupt
keine unkraut probleme in unserem garten
wir haben 300 quadratmeter mietfläche
und brauchen ungefähr drei minuten im
monat um das ganze zu jäten liegt vor
allem an der art wie wir unsere beete
anlegen aber auch an der art wie wir die
die lese dann am ende behandeln mulchen
kannst du deinen knoblauch allerdings
nicht zu dick ich würde da maximal fünf
zentimeter aus bringen damit das ganze
nicht foult aber viele leute sagen man
kann ihn überhaupt nicht mulchen ich
mich den immer und hatte damit noch nie
probleme aber dicke habe
ich jetzt noch nicht getraut in unseren
kompost beten ist eine stimmung nicht
unbedingt nötig wenn man knoblauch
anbaut wenn du im normalen mutterboden
anbaus kommt ein bisschen darauf an wie
viele nährstoffe natürlich im boden
vorhanden sind
du siehst aus dem knoblauch im
frühsommer oft an wenn er relativ früh
schon gelbe blattspitzen oder gelbe
blätter bekommt dann kannst du den ein
bisschen mit brennessel jauche
aufpäppeln da freut er sich auf jeden
fall darüber aber dünn ist bei knoblauch
nicht unbedingt nötig was dann
irgendwann an steht wer das aufbrechen
der knospen im sommer im frühsommer
gebildet dann blütenknospen und wenn du
richtig schön dicke knollen ernten
willst dann ist es relativ wichtig dass
man die blüten knospen ausbricht die
kammern auch frisch essen die sind super
lecker wie kann man sogar fermentieren
ich trockene die auch gerne oder koche
die sogar ein macht daraus pesto also
die schmecken sehr sehr mild nach
knoblauch da kann man dann wenn
vielleicht der lager knoblauch schon
langsam aus geht einfach auf die knospen
übergehen und die eine zeitlang essen
damit die pflanzen nicht blühen und ihre
energie in die blüte lenken und in die
brut knöllchen die dann entstehen die
man ja auch zum pflanzen verwenden kann
die man auch essen kann aber die sehr
sehr klein sind und felix sind und wo
man lange warten muss bis man daraus
knoblauch anbauen kann ist es meiner
meinung nach ganz sinnvoll die knospen
auszubrechen einfach abbrechen und dann
steckt die pflanze ihre ganze energie
bis zur ernte nur noch in die knolle und
das ist wie ich finde eine sehr wichtige
maßnahme damit ein anderen auch ein
richtig guter ernte hat wenn ihr noch
tipps habt zum knoblauch anbauen oder
auch für knoblauch sorten dann schreib
das auf jeden fall in die kommentare ich
finde es mal super schön wenn wir hier
alle voneinander lernen und nicht nur
ich diejenige bin die ich hier irgendwie
vorträge halte also freue ich mich auf
jeden fall von euch zu hören gibt dem
video einen daumen nach oben wenn es
euch gefallen hat damit könnt ihr mich
wirklich richtig gut unterstützen also
das ist etwas was meinem kanal wirklich
gut weiterhilft ansonsten sind die da
drüben eine playlist zum haltbarmachen
wenn ihr einen garten habe dann erntet
er wahrscheinlich gerade eine ganze
menge
und da findet ihr tipps zum verwerten
und haltbar machen da unten ist auch
noch ein video das euch interessieren
könnte an
sonst sehen wir ins nächsten samstag
wieder biss dann tschüss gebt dem daumen
ein
gebt dem daumen